- So it's a weird story.
It's weird, everything.
I've been working on something
with a longtime friend and--
and a client.
I don't even-- I don't even
know how to explain it, man.
The client's cars, you know,
they arrived last night.
And this gentleman is looking
to auction these vehicles off.
They're great cars.
So the whole object of the game
is to not change the integrity
of the cars because that would
change the value of the cars
because of who the client is.
It's-- it's-- uh.
What the client wanted--
the client is not--
who the client was.
And I got-- I got a long-time
history with this cat,
and it goes all the
way back to the '80s.
But the client on these cars,
I'm gonna show you right now.
No kidding.
It was-- it was Burt Reynolds.
- The Burt Reynolds?
- The Burt Reynolds.
Oh, man.
It's like, there's not a
lot of people that I idolize,
but that--
that is the man right there.
It's-- it's really--
it's really tough.
I love this guy.
We shared a building together
when I lived in South Florida.
We knew each other
pretty, pretty well.
And he's a huge car
guy and just one
of the coolest cats
you'd ever want to know.
So the whole object of
the game is, you know,
the Barrett-Jackson auction
is right around the corner.
And he had a few vehicles
that he wanted to prepare
for the auction to sell.
And I was the guy that he
trusted to send the vehicles to
and get them ready for auction.
You know, he wants all the
proceeds-- wants the proceeds
to go, you know, to a retired
stuntman foundation, you know,
because he's really
big into that stuff.
Here's the thing, men.
The goal is to carry
out the man's wishes,
make them beautiful again, like
I was saying, without changing
the integrity of the car.
They're his personal cars.
And so I just want to do a
whole bunch of straightening out
some things, touching
up some things,
buffing out some things,
just making them beautiful,
and getting them ready.
OK.
Can we look at these cars?
It's killing me.
Yeah.
This is really what
you think they are.
Oh, goodness.
DANNY: This is actually--
that's actually Burt's
personal "Hooper" Trans-Am.
This is really the one Burt's
personal "Bandit" Trans-Am.
Wow.
And the truck up
there, the crew cab
Dually from "Cannonball Run."
Hey, is that the truck
with the guy that talked
like a bear or something in it?
- Yeah.
With the overalls.
DANNY: That's the one.
- Yeah.
- Man, is that the jet car?
DANNY: That's--
that's-- that's-- yeah,
that's the jet one.
- What?
Oh, my goodness.
DANNY: I know, dude.
We're just going to make
them as beautiful as possible
for the stuntman foundation.
Don't you worry.
We'll take very
good care of them.
You know I won't drive it.
DANNY: To be honest with you, I
drove this one home last night,
just-- just because I could.
You know what I'm saying?
I would too, man.
Drive like in the movies.
Yeah, I jumped the
bridge coming home.
So gentlemen, just,
thank you, guys.
And I'm going to try and clear
my head, get a cup of coffee.
- Relax.
- Get the ball rolling.
Thank you, guys.
Sorry you lost your boy.
Amen, we did.
We lost a star.
Not-- not-- not a
celebrity, a star.
Yeah.
Man, you talk about literally
an emotional roller coaster,
I was so psyched when
Burt's people told me
that the cars were coming in.
I didn't even get a chance
to tell the guys when I got
the call that Burt had passed.
I mean, literally, I got
the cars the night before.
So I just gotta say,
man, this project
has gone from fun
to just really,
really, really important.
I love Burt on screen.
And I loved this man as I
got to know him off screen.
I'm truly going
to miss this cat.
This guy was a legend.
Burt Reynolds' cars.
Mike, no playing
with the CB, Mike.
CB.
It's got the CB in it.
[rock music playing]
DANNY: You know, we've done
a lot of special projects
here at Count's Kustoms.
But I gotta say, man, getting
Burt Reynolds' couple of very
personal cars, very famous
cars, ready for auction for him,
that's huge.
That's big.
That means a lot to me.
Burt was a friend.
He was somebody I knew
an awfully long time ago.
And he was a huge legend.
And we said goodbye to Burt
not too terribly long ago.
And now we're saying goodbye
to two of his beautiful cars.